bootleg cab show special guests in here
my guy it's been too long been too long
man T grizzly my brother good to see you
again bro you've been outside yeah I
never went inside during the pandemic
even outside man I've been trying and
listen you've been inside running up a
check you understand I've been on Twitch
I've been on GTA dog you gotta help me
understand because I just saw this clip
of you asking a little kid
if he was gonna pick his mom or the
homies and then you smoked them and then
you drove off
what the [ __ ] is this role-playing GTA
explain this thing yeah so you're
explaining that situation yes let's just
start off with that because okay so
basically right it was it was just I
could tell he was young
you feel me
but he was already deep off the edge
into the streets you know what I'm
saying and he wanted to join Grizzly
game
you know so I'm like all right bet you
know I'ma show you everything and see if
this is what you really want so I showed
him everything right so now at this
point
if we don't put them down he gotta go
because he know too much
so I asked him a question the last part
initiation I was about to put him in
Grizzly game that's my question I said
this your new family now ain't no ain't
your regular family this over this Trump
everything once you become a part of
this you know what I'm saying so I asked
I'm like bro I'm actually a question
don't hesitate
you feel me because if you hesitate at
me you gotta think about it I need you
to be sure I'm like so who your favorite
person in your family like my brother
I'm like all right bet if your brother's
standing right here and one of the
members standing right here you got to
shoot whenever you're gonna shoot and he
hesitated so he had to go so you killed
him yeah wow
I'm I really need to get to the roots of
this entire world so
by the way I'm so happy for you that you
have because I think it's incredible
that you have uh
turned your love for gaming into like a
real incredible like stream of income
um
I don't understand the role-playing
thing so it's a it's it's like a server
you have your own server yeah I got my
own server Grizzly World RP so in this
world this is like you have a gang yeah
and when you guys are in the world on
the headphones and [ __ ] y'all are like
really acting yeah like acting like
that's the real world when we on there
right when we all know the real world
don't exist like that's the real world
wow that's deep it's kind of like
Dungeons and Dragons but like on on a
video game kinda do you remember
Dungeons and Dragons yeah yeah that's
crazy yeah you know what it's exactly
like that but but funner yeah what's the
Grand Theft Auto it's crazy
will you uh are you like kind of sad
that the new GTA is coming it means
you're gonna probably eventually have to
retire the OG no
because we're gonna move the whole thing
over to the whole new build that's gonna
be better I can't wait for it to drop so
okay take me to the roots of this so
obviously you're a fan of video gaming
you've been gaming online at what point
in time do you get introduced to having
your own server role playing and
building this I mean you have like a
twitch Empire yeah it was it was during
covet bro it was during covert I was on
Call of Duty heavy streaming Call of
Duty and um somebody told me you got to
try GTA out right so I'll be on Call of
Duty Trolling right like then you you
gotta try GTA out right you feel me I
tried it I'm like no this [ __ ] actually
fun and my numbers wanna
on GTA yeah because it's more
entertaining I could really like be
myself on there yeah yeah some Street
[ __ ] you're running around yeah exactly
so that was like this is a no-brainer
and it just went up did you ever think
when you're sitting in a jail cell
waiting to get out not knowing what was
on you know the other rest the side of
your life that you'd be getting paid the
amount of money you'd be getting paid to
play video games and act that's crazy
out the [ __ ] you used to do yeah I know
that existed bro
it's so crazy man yeah it's super crazy
for sure guys like yourself T-Pain's
been doing this thing you know I mean
yeah what has been your most successful
month on Twitch
my most successful month
this month been very successful yeah
you've been going viral this month yeah
this might have been very successful on
Twitch for sure and I ain't even been
able to stream but not to be all in your
pockets but like what's that look like
it looked crazy like I could show you
like this month so far
and twitch got to start taking care of
creators a little better so this is
because everything been going viral so
that's this one so far
oh my God
yeah that's six figures yeah
can I say the amount a hundred fifteen
thousand dollars yeah in a month playing
video games oh yeah why would you ever
go to a club again
I don't mail mad at me right now
mad at me right now because um
I don't know I mean like this is the way
I look you can't show nobody like me
that you can make money from home
because I want to be home anyway well I
was gonna say like
you obviously can always put out music
uh but like why open yourself up to like
unnecessary risk for like 20 grand to go
to a club or do 30 grand to go to a club
when you could just chill at the crib
yeah be safe not worry about no [ __ ]
and uh you know just talk [ __ ] on the
internet in fact I don't do it though
I ain't been to a Cleveland it's been a
minute I was gonna say do you feel like
you're a professional gamer part-time
rapper now
um I feel like I'm a professional gamer
part-time movie director which is uh
obviously coming out with it with the
project yeah yeah and um I don't rapping
them up bro
I just I just make movies now
straight up yeah so you're just kind of
it is what it is yeah
I'm I'm making a move I'm into the movie
thing now
and this is everybody rapping it's a new
rapper every day everybody rapping oh I
rap sound the same to me
so I'd just rather just do the movie
thing